bien nous allons pouvoir commencer
maintenant que notre rapporteur est
arrivé en courant et sous la pluie
visiblement
mes chers collègues dans nous voici
réunis pour entendre aujourd'hui le
point de vue des départements et des
régions de France sur l'avenir des
communes et des maires le sujet de notre
de notre mission et j'ai donc le plaisir
de saluer monsieur le Président du
Conseil départemental de l'Allier
monsieur Claude Riboulet merci d'être
venu jusqu'à nous et vous intervenez au
titre de l'Assemblée des départements de
France et vous êtes accompagné de
Monsieur Jérôme Briand et Madame
Maryline joue bien qui vous êtes
conseiller à la DF et en visioconférence
nous avons Monsieur Laurent Dejoie qui
est vice-président du Conseil régional
des Pays de la Loire qui interviennent
qui interviendra pour région de France
je crois si vous nous entendez très bien
bonjour bonjour
merci aux collègues présents et fidèle a
toujours à nos auditions et vous êtes à
chaque fois nombreux merci de nous
accompagner dans ces travaux en
messieurs vos associations représentent
les deux autres niveaux de collectivités
territoriales et bien sûr votre analyse
et votre réaction sur le sujet qui nous
occupe nous intéresse à plusieurs titres
comme déjà acteurs et observateurs de la
vie locale et comme aussi partenaire des
communes aussi ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est le regard que vous
portez sur la situation actuelle des
communes sur leur place dans
l'organisation territoriale et sur leur
avenir nous cette mission a été
déclenchée suite à un constat d'une
tendance un peu préoccupante de
nombreuses démissions depuis la nouvelle
élection de 2020
donc c'est ce que vous avez aussi cette
cette approche là cette inquiétude là
est qu'en est-il aussi des
collaborations entre vos collectivités
et les communes et quelle politique vous
mettez en oeuvre à destination des
communes et si vous avez connaissance de
bonnes pratiques ou de dispositif d'aide
aux communes qui permettent à celle-ci
de faire face aux difficultés et aux
défis qu'elles rencontrent nous sommes
preneurs de vos avis alors avant de vous
donner la parole je vais passer la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur pour
petits mots d'accueil
merci madame la Présidente je salue à
mon tour nos deux invités du jour
Monsieur Riboulet présente département
de l'Allier qui intervient pour la DF et
Monsieur de joie pour région de France
je souscris bien évidemment aux propos
que vient de tenir la présidence c'est
vrai que après avoir fait déjà un tour
de certains territoires et de plusieurs
départements de France dans le cadre de
notre mission nous observons jour après
jour que le département c'est un lien
historique mais également que les
régions jouent un rôle de plus en plus
majeur dans l'accompagnement des
communes sur quelques sujets que que ce
soit qui vont de la question de
l'ingénierie qui est une question
centrale question sur laquelle il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire dans le lien
qu'entretiennent les communes avec avec
l'État notamment et donc un besoin de de
plus en plus grand d'avoir ces deux
niveaux de collectivités aux côtés des
communes et puis dans la capacité aussi
de prendre en compte des particularismes
territoriaux dans un temps où on parle
de plus en plus de différenciation c'est
vrai que et on l'a vu que ce soit dans
la somme que ce soit dans les Vosges en
Haute-Garonne nous étions encore dans
dans l'Ille-et-Vilaine les spécificités
territoriales l'appelles de plus en plus
l'accompagnement des communes par ces
deux niveaux de collectivité par des
politiques contractuelles qui permettent
de prendre en compte aussi les
spécificités territoriales et c'est
pourquoi nous sommes aujourd'hui ravis
de pouvoir échanger avec vous d'avoir
votre lecture sur sur ces sujets et
peut-être pourrez-vous nous dire dans
vos propos respectifs quel est votre
vision du lien
qu'il y a à renforcer la nature du lien
renforcé avec avec les communes quels
sont selon vous les sujets sur lesquels
à la fois les départements et les
régions doivent encore pouvoir
travailler et puis ce qui relève aussi
du champ législatif et ce sur quoi vous
êtes encore en attente
par Lyon la semaine dernière avec le
président sauvadé d'un sujet qui est
épineux et qu'il sera de plus en plus
c'est celui de l'eau où on a besoin là
aussi d'avoir une agilité très forte et
encore une fois de savoir répondre aux
problématiques territoriales et locales
dans un temps où on annonce encore un
été un niveau de sécheresse parfois
parfois record voilà un petit peu ce que
je souhaitais vous dire
en propos liminaire et puis après nous
passerons bien évidemment la parole à
l'ensemble des collègues qui sont ici et
qui participent à cette mission
d'information
par
le Président si vous le souhaitez en
présence
à votre discrétion madame la Présidente
sur le rapporteur mesdames messieurs
régional vous avez prévu qu'on fasse un
échange peut-être par
séquence de thématique puisque vous en
avez abordé un certain nombre moi je
m'en remets à la méthodologie qui sera
la vôtre évidemment alors vous voyez un
petit questionnaire donc vous nous ferez
sûrement passer un
bâton vous nous donnez aussi votre
préliminaire peut-être votre avis sur la
question et sur sur le cœur de sujet de
cette mission alors d'abord une remarque
liminaire de de sémantique sur
l'intitulé même de la mission l'avenir
de la commune et du maire et je me suis
interrogé en disant pourquoi il y a une
dissociation entre la commune Elmer qui
en fait sont parfaitement attirés ce
qu'on craint que peut-être l'indice
avant l'autre et le propos de prambule
que vous évoquiez quant à la démission
d'un certain nombre de mère en exercice
depuis la mandature 2020 peut
effectivement nourrir cette subtilité
sémantique quant à l'avenir de
l'institution commune en tant que tel
mais qui tient davantage aux conseils
municipal et à la fonction particulière
du maire qui est pas une fonction il est
au suffrage universel direct dans
l'exercice de la représentation de la
personne morale
première remarque pour essayer de
répondre à cette question aujourd'hui de
l'organisation et de la place de la
commune par rapport aux autres
collectivités je crois qu'il faut la
reposer dans un contexte qui a quasiment
un quart de siècle maintenant depuis la
loi Chevènement de 99 que j'appelle une
période de tectonique des plaques la
vérité c'est que ça fait 25 ans qu'on a
les plaques de l'organisation
territoriale de la République
décentralisée qui glisse qui
s'entrechoquent parfois avec plus ou
moins de douceur parfois avec plus ou
moins de brutalité parfois générant
quelques ondes de choc et quelques
séismes pour pas dire des répliques et
parfois se faisant de façon beaucoup
plus
invisible et à ce titre là
j'ai tendance à penser que la commune a
été comme les départements demeurant
dans cette tectonique des plaques parmi
les institutions les plus les plus
chahutés et que le parcours sur 25 ans
est un parcours qui est assez
intéressant
oui vous aviez raison de rappeler tout à
l'heure que le l'articulation commune
département était historiquement pendant
des décennies pour panier depuis la
Révolution française une articulation
assez simple la commune dans l'ultra
proximité le département on le sait à
une demi-journée de cheval pour aller à
la préfecture et chaque jour de canton
étant des choix intermédiaire j'observe
qu'en fait tout ça respecter
scrupuleusement ce qu'on formulera
beaucoup plus tard après la révolution
de principe de subsidiarité les champs
de proximité est toujours le meilleur
échelon pour porter une politique
publique les genoux supérieur à partir
de là respectant l'autonomie de
l'échelon dit infra en revanche quand
les genoux supérieurs en l'occurrence le
département par rapport à la commune et
sollicité c'est le principe de
suppléance qui s'applique et on se doit
de venir en accompagnement en aide et en
appui tout ça a été notamment
avec effectivement la création des
intercommunalités on a pu penser au
moins un temps que c'était du côté des
EPCI que la commune allait chercher le
partenaire plus logique et plus spontané
sauf qu'en fait on voit qu'il y a eu au
fil de ces 25 ans disait-je l'évolution
de deux façons des EPCI celles qui ont
été très intégratrices et qui d'une
certaine façon plutôt vider la commune
d'une partie de leur substances et de
leur capacités d'action la compétence
étant strictement transférée à l'échelle
intercommunale avec une instance de
décision dont on connaît le relatif
éloignement par rapport au Conseil
municipal avec une modalité démocratique
de représentation qui n'est pas stricto
sensu le suffrage universel direct soit
par fléchage dans les communes de plus
de 1000 soit par ordre du tableau dans
les communes de moins de 1000 avec
j'observe au passage permettez-moi de le
dire tout de suite j'y reviendrai
peut-être ce que j'appelle une anomalie
à date l'intercommunalité qui n'est pas
collectivité territoriale au sens
constitutionnel et la dernière strat a
bénéficié d'un double pouvoir de
fiscalité directe locale la taxe sur le
fonds la taxe sur la distribution
foncière des entreprises d'autre part
les communes n'ont plus que le foncier
bâti le département 0 les régions zéro
et qu'on peut s'interroger quel que soit
la revendication du président dataire
communauté de France sur cette de mon
point de vue incongruité de la moins
démocratique des instances quant à la
représentation au conseil communautaire
et de la plus libre en terme de pouvoir
fiscal direct donc je reviens en dehors
de cette digression sur l'idée
qu'effectivement on a cru que la commune
pouvait s'accrocher à l'intercommunalité
mais soit ça a été un transfert de
compétences et là pour le coup ça plutôt
été dévitalisation des communes soit
cela était des intercommités de projet
qui se sont donnés comme objectif de
faire à plusieurs ce qu'aucun pouvait
faire soi-même dans l'intérêt d'un
bassin de vie d'un territoire à
structurer ou aménager et dans les
compétences telles que la loi
Chevènement les avait dévolus a commencé
par le développement économique plus le
reste au fil du temps et auquel cas
c'est pas véritablement la commune qui
s'est vu accompagnée elle a plutôt vu
quelqu'un fait à sa place des choses
qu'elle ne faisait pas elle-même le
marqueur je crois qui est très important
c'est celui de
2017 avec les grandes politiques de
réorganisation territoriale que
j'appelle la mode du XXL des très
grandes régions et avec les SDCI 2017
des très grandes intercommunalités tout
compte fait en creux ça redonné au
département un rôle et une place
consolidée comme un échelon
d'articulation entre les très grandes
régions avec vocations stratégique qui
renforcée et avec le bloc local commune
intercommunalité mais à des périmètres
qui ne sont plus ceux des bassins de vie
et à ce moment-là la commune a pu avoir
le sentiment d'être déclassé c'est en
2019 avec le phénomène des gilets jaunes
que d'aucun se rendent compte de
l'utilité de l'ultra proximité du maire
si le président sevadait défend le
département comme la collectivité du
dernier kilomètre on peut dire que la
commune et le maire c'est la
collectivité du dernier maître et comme
le dirait le président du Sénat je peux
me le permettre ici les mers les
conseillers municipaux sont les élus
apportés d’engueulade que ce soit dans
la rue sur le marché ou dans leur bureau
et c'est donc en 2019 qu'on revoit lu
l'utilité de l'ultra proximité au
quotidien de la commune je nous permet
d'ajouter que la gestion la crise
sanitaire de 2020 du premier confinement
jusqu'au début des campagnes de
vaccination a montré aussi la pertinence
des communes ce qui se pose aujourd'hui
pour répondre à cette première question
et je m'en tiendrai là avant de passer
la deuxième thématique de la trame mais
peut-être que mon collègue de la région
raconte l'été c'est qu'on voit que la
commune a été plutôt ballotée entre un
vieux pacte avec le département
ballotage au gré des flots du côté des
intercommunalités et avec selon aussi
qu'on est dans une métropole une
agglomération ou une communauté de
communes plus rurale et plus modeste une
place qui est différente à tenir et
aujourd'hui quand on en tout cas besoin
d'un repère c'est toujours vers elle
qu'on se tourne ce qui pose la question
de l'articulation des politiques
publiques et pas simplement celle de la
communauté du maire davantage en termes
de périmètre de bassin de vie ou encore
une fois de subsidiarité qu'en termes de
périmètre administratif je prendrai à ce
stade la seule illustration vous évoquez
monsieur sénateur sur l'eau si l'eau
relevée d'un périmètre administratif
quelconque qu'on s'en serait rendu
compte la seule réalité qui prime c'est
le bassin versant la réalité naturelle
des gisements de la ressource et de la
manière de la collecter de la distribuer
et de la renvoyer au milieu naturel et
c'est certainement pas un périmètre
administratif d'intercommunalité qui
peut être l'alpha et le méga de la bonne
gestion d'une ressource essentielle en
crise aujourd'hui voilà sur cette
première idée et vous l'avez compris
autant je défends la commune comme un
échange incontournable de premier niveau
autant je pense que le département a pu
aussi par rapport à la commune être un
point d'ancrage auquel elle a su qu'elle
pouvait rester arrimer sans avoir de
crainte d'être lâché en race campagne ce
qui me permettra dans un deuxième temps
de venir sur l'accompagnement
peut-être vous donner la parole monsieur
de joie
je suis très heureux de représenter
région de France cet après-midi d'autant
plus que mon parcours personnel
me prête à beaucoup d'attention sur la
question que vous posez j'ai été maire
de 1995 à 2014 de Vertou une commune
25000 habitants dans la région nantaise
qui touche Nantes et j'ai été
vice-président non exécutif de la
métropole nantaise pendant cette même
durée
moi je prends le titre de votre
commission comme un signal d'optimisme
pour la commune puisque vous parlez de
son avenir or je me souviens que dans
les années 2000 il y avait une tentative
de ringardisation de la commune j'ai
même entendu des gens dire qu'il fallait
substituer au triptyque comme une
département-état celui de
l'intercommunalité de la région et de
l'Europe et cette cette mouvement de
pensée il a duré jusqu'au comme le
disait le président Riboulet au fond
jusque les années
2015-2016 avec la la loi nôtre et puis
bien évidemment comme chaque fois qu'il
y a des excès le
rééquilibrage et est intervenu
un constat que la commune a été un
échelon indispensable et ce constat il a
été largement accrue par l'effet de la
crise sanitaire qui a montré
l'importance du maire et de la commune
comme premier échelon de la démocratie
et le rôle du maire lui-même premier
contact alors apporter de d'engueulades
à portée de baffe selon les selon
l'expression qu'on veut utiliser mais
surtout premier contact pour le citoyen
qui en manque tant aujourd'hui et qui se
heurtent si souvent à un répondeur
téléphonique ou à questionnaire par
ordinateur alors pour autant je
considère que votre commission est bien
mieux il y a encore beaucoup à faire
dans la mesure où les atteintes au rôle
des communes
se font aujourd'hui plus discrète mais
parfois aussi efficace ou plus efficace
il y a d'abord les contraintes
financières le président et voulait l'a
rappelé la taxe d'habitation donc a
disparu pour les communes et
certes il reste la taxe foncière mais la
stabilité on a une stabilité des
recettes en tout cas une des recettes
qui qui sont très encadrées et un
dynamisme des dépenses dans le mauvais
sens d'ailleurs la plupart du temps qui
fait que la citation des financières des
communes n'a pas tendance à s'arranger
il y a la question des compétences ou le
mouvement est encore d'essayer
d'orienter les compétences les plus
stratégiques vers l'intercommunalité ou
vers d'autres collectivités
et de maintenir par contre les
compétences d'hyperproximité mais
souvent les plus coûteuses les plus
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre et les
plus risqués entre guillemets au sein de
la commune et on voit par exemple des
compétences aussi importantes que celles
de l'urbanisme
et son
accessoire si je veux dire le logement
qui pour les communes soit leur échappe
totalement avec aujourd'hui les PLU
intercommunaux de plus en plus fréquents
des contraintes alors de toutes parts et
notamment la dernière née le zéro
artificialisation nette qui d'ailleurs
pose la question des relations des
collectivités entre elles et notamment
la Région et la commune j'y reviendrai
dans mon promo puis dans les questions
que vous nous poserez peut-être tout à
l'heure alors le logement je vous en ai
touché un mot en particulier le logement
social que le maire doit donc intégrer
dans sa commune ou se voit imposer par
l'intercommunalité le tel ou telle
manière ou par la loi tout en étant de
moins en moins influents pour
l'attribution des logements ou pour les
commanderais-je le fonctionnement
quotidien de ces logements sociaux
il y a également des phénomènes qui
aujourd'hui sont menaçants pour la
commune et son maire c'est la judiciaire
la judiciarisation de la vie publique
dans deux directions les communes
elles-mêmes avec les recours
administratifs notamment en matière
d'urbanisme la question est tellement
connue que je n'insiste pas mais aussi
la judiciarisation pour les élus
eux-mêmes attaqués parfois de de toutes
parts et qui deviennent des cibles enfin
dans tous les domaines et pas que
judiciaire d'ailleurs on a eu
malheureusement quelques exemples
l'inflation normative
[Musique]
elle est toujours aussi prégnante et je
me souviens que l'un des premiers
rapports du Conseil d'État qui dénonçait
cela et de 1981 il disait qu'en droit
bavarde le citoyen ne lui prête plus
qu'une oreille distraite on peut pas
dire que la citation soit beaucoup
améliorée depuis 1991 alors pour avant
de terminer pour pour améliorer les
choses sans doute il va falloir qu'on
clarifie un peu mieux l'articulation
entre la commune et l'intercommunalité
et notamment
comment dirais je les pouvoirs que peut
conserver le maire au sein de
l'intercommunalité et qui avec des
différences de traitement par exemple
selon la taille des intercommunalités on
constate que dans les je parle pas
forcément de la taille en puissance de
population mais qu'il faut en nombre de
communes quand vous avez peu de communes
souvent le poids de la ville semble être
très fort à tout point de vue et puis
dans les communes ou dans les
intercommunalités où ils sont
extrêmement nombreuses les communes vous
avez une dilution du pouvoir ce qui
redonne aux communes même les plus
petites des pouvoirs intéressants donc
ça c'est peut-être des choses qu'il
faudra regarder où généralisé il y a
l'article alors l'articulation avec les
régions
bon à notre sens à nos régions les
choses se passent bien c'est vrai que le
plus souvent dans certaines de nos
compétences nous avons à faire
directement à l'intercommunalité et
qu'on a du mal
supposé qu'on le veuille d'ailleurs à
toucher la commune directement
puisqu'elle a elle n'a plus telle ou
telle compétence c'est vrai notamment en
matière économique même si parfois avec
les fonds structurels européens donc
nous avons pour l'essentiel la
distribution nous retrouvons des des
liens directs avec le avec les communes
avec les communes elles-mêmes et donc le
dernier péril que je voulais signaler
qui est un peu la conséquence d'un
certain nombre de choses que je viens de
vous dire c'est qu'effectivement on
risque de bientôt de ne plus trouver de
maire ou d'élus municipaux moi je nous
constatons y compris dans ma région des
démissions des lieux municipaux de plus
en plus importantes pour des raisons
sans doute
différentes et de et de plus en plus
nombreuses mais il est il est
vraisemblable qu'il y a eu un décalage
entre l'attente des élus quand ils sont
quand ils arrivent dans une municipalité
c'est vrai beaucoup de consignes
municipaux et la réalité de ce qu'ils
ont à accomplir comme tâches ou comme
mission et il se trouve confronté à des
limites de pouvoir qu'il n'avaient pas
forcément imaginer ce qui est le
provoquer chez eux une démission et puis
on voit bien que de plus en plus
certaines catégories de de
socioprofessionnelles n'acceptent plus
au monde à municipaux parce que parce
qu'il y a trop de contraintes parce
qu'il y a trop de
judiciarisation il y a trop de
transparence il y a trop de sociétés de
cela le monde de l'entreprise qui soit
salarié ou chef d'entreprise les
professions libérales il y a beaucoup de
métiers qui ne sont plus représentés
parce que ça leur paraît beaucoup trop
compliqué voire même risqué par rapport
à leur activité professionnelle
les et puis ça aussi mais je crois que
ici au Sénat
j'espère prêcher pour des gens
convaincus là le nom cumul des mandats a
eu un effet désastreux sur comment
dirais toutes ces questions là également
puisque ça
[Musique]
provoqué effectivement une perte
apparente de pouvoir en taux réel même
chez certains voilà le propos
introductif que vous m'aviez demandé de
faire et je suis à votre disposition non
pour répondre aux questions que vous
pourriez avoir et pour vous transmettre
ou vous faire transmettre le
questionnaire que nous avons reçu et qui
sera adressé par écrit comme on l'a
demandé
je vous remercie
non ce qui est intéressant merci déjà de
votre contribution à aller à l'autre ce
qui ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
effectivement et ça me permet en écho à
ce que disait le président Riboulet sur
l'exercice de sémantique qui fut le
nôtre au moment du choix de cette
mission effectivement non pas
nécessairement de distinguer le maire de
la commune mais est-ce que vous avez dit
EL1 et l'autre c'est qu'il y a eu
effectivement
après
que certains aient eu la tentation
de
d'installer
un couple à trois intercommunalités
région et Europe un retour par le prisme
de cette notion de proximité qui est
aujourd'hui revendiqué et que nous sur
laquelle nous essayons de faire porter
un petit peu la réflexion convaincue que
que ce soit le département la région
la commune la volonté et de rendre un
service je veux dire un mot à nos
concitoyens quel qu'il soit quel qu'en
soit la
compétence et c'est un constat que j'ai
pu observer dans vos propos sur lequel
encore une fois nous essayons de faire
porter la la réflexion moi j'avais
j'avais une première question sur
ce première partie de vos interventions
vous avez rappelé notamment le lien et
parfois la difficulté parce que
l'intercommunalité je m'empresse de dire
que nous considérons que
c'est un c'est une strate
utile en ce qu'elle permet en ce qu'elle
permet de de mutualiser de faire naître
des projets qui aujourd'hui ne
pourraient pas être porté par par les
seules communes mais on voit aussi la
complexité que génère certaines
intercommunalités nous étions jeudi
dernier dans la Somme on voit que là
aussi on a opéré une forme de
recentralisation le président Riboulet
le disait à l'instant et ma question
elle est très simple finalement comment
selon vous on peut réinstaller que ce
soit au niveau régional ou au niveau
départemental une proximité un
accompagnement
utile et pragmatique de la commune j'ai
volontairement pris les l'exemple de
l'ingénierie parce que si on veut que la
commune est un avenir faut-il encore
quel est les moyens on a aujourd'hui
une réflexion sur et on a été beaucoup
interpellé sur la politique d'appel à
projet de l'État qui est une complexité
supplémentaire pour que les mères
puissent se répondre finalement
c'était assez de politique d'appel à
projet et donc tout simplement faire
émerger des projets sur leur sur leur
territoire mais on voit bien la
difficulté que cela revêt et donc le
recours assez systématique à la strate
départementale et à la strate régionale
et puis la deuxième deuxième question
tout aussi tout aussi pragmatique et
pratique on voit bien la
difficulté
du lien aujourd'hui entre les
collectivités et l'État je dirais même
plus entre la commune et l'État alors
peut-être un peu moins avec l'État
territorial mais dès lors qu'on est sur
un échelon supra notamment les
directions régionales on voit bien la
difficulté et donc la tentation
naturelle des maires à se tourner vers
la collectivité des départementales et
la collectivité régionale comment vous
voyez cette cette évolution là qui est
souvent une évolution qui est une des
explications du découragement de
certains élus on a l'impression que
l'avenir s'écrit sans eux que tout est
devenu très compliqué et donc la fronde
va grandissante et par la même que c'est
une des façons en tout cas c'est une
façon qu'on les met d'exprimer justement
ce ras-le-bol et cette incapacité à
faire cette forme un peu de désespérance
convaincu que ils ont besoin plutôt d'un
état accompagnateur qu'un État un état
censeur
le président
il y a beaucoup d'idées chez le reporter
je vais essayer de plus synthétique que
sur ma première intervention première
remarque pour revenir en trois secondes
sur le titre de cette mission j'avais en
fait une idée en tête une arrière-pensée
c'est qu'on sait aussi qu'il y a des
organisations qui définissent le rôle du
maire délégué c'est le cas pour les
grandes villes avec les maires
d'arrondissement c'est le cas pour les
communes nouvelles et que la question
qu'on peut aussi poser dans le cadre de
la mission que vous présidez madame
c'est est-ce que demain on considère
qu'il y aura un maire uniforme dans sa
fonction et par rapport à quel que soit
l'organisation de la commune ou est-ce
qu'on peut penser aussi une
responsabilité différenciée par la
fonction existante aujourd'hui des mers
délégués si on fait référence au commune
nouvelle dont je me permets de rappeler
qu'il s'agissait d'ailleurs d'un
contrefeu fondé par l'AMF et son
président à l'époque pour éviter une
disparition massive et brutale des
communes en France
dans les questions que vous posez je
crois qu'il y a deux choses qui doivent
être refondés je me permettrai pas de
porter de jugement et je vais revenir
concrètement sur l'article gestion qui
était partout
c'est quoi la vision qu'on a dans ce
pays en fait aujourd'hui
moi je salue une initiative au mission
mais en fait la France de 2030 puisque
vous posez aussi le rôle du maire à
l'échéance d'une quinzaine d'années
c'est quoi c'est celle la start-up
nation
c'est une France modèle britannique avec
quelques centaines de communes c'est une
France réorganisée comme une nouvelle
donc on n'aura pas clairement répondu à
cette question
et en acceptant qu'une fois que la
réponse est donnée elle doit s'inscrire
dans une continuité de temps
confère mon propos luminaire sur la
tectonique des plaques ça peut pas
trembler tous les quatre cinq ans c'est
pas possible je crois qu'on aura pas
répondu aux questions suivantes je le
dis comme je le pense ce que les lois de
réforme territoriales n'ont pas réussi à
faire à visage ouvert insidieusement les
lois de finances en sont chargées chaque
année
et que chaque fois qu'il s'est agit de
malmener un échelon quelconque de
l'organisation territoriale s'il y avait
un front des élus pour défendre à 23h et
calque un article de la loi de finances
suffisait par exemple à faire rentrer
dans les variables d'ajustement les
fonds de garantie de la taxe
professionnelle ou des ressources
individuelles qui étaient sacralisées
soi-disant et qui sont quand même
rentrés dans les variables d'ajustement
à faire sauter tel ou tel modalité
particulière de ressources etc j'en
passe et des pires à partir de là
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas non
plus négliger le fait que les EPCI
soient chronophage pour les élus
prenez la température en direct des mers
et des conseillers communautaires ils
ont plus de temps de réunions générés
par l'intercommunalité entre les
commissions les sous-commissions les
conseils communautaires les bureaux les
bureaux exécutifs etc que par leur
propre commune et en plus dans des
assemblées à plusieurs dizaines où il y
a plus d'auddibilité individuelles de
chacun à partir de là je crois que les
départements il y a un rôle qu'on a déjà
commencé de jouer qui est important
l'ingénierie territoriale on se rappelle
aussi juste les choses il y a moins de
10 ans c'était le grand retrait de
l'État dans l'ingénierie le droit des
sols pour les documents d'urbanisme les
conseils qui n'étaient plus des conseils
opérés par les DDT divers et variés et
on se retournait soit vers les
intercoses vers les départements disant
prenez le relais
j'ai toujours défendu je continuerai de
défendre le rôle des sous-préfectures et
des sous-préfets aujourd'hui moi je
plains les sous préfets les
sous-préfetes de ce pays quand on voit
malheureusement le peu d'administration
territorialisée de l'État qui le reste
en sous-préfecture alors qu'avant on
savait que c'était le premier guichet de
soutien et d'appui du maire tu sais moi
j'ai été du concierger en 2001 ça fait
22 ans j'ai été conseillé municipal
depuis 1995 adjoint mère est présent
depuis 2017 avant je me rappelais très
bien on disait le maire c'est le
sous-préfet son interlocuteur ou la
sous-préfète quand on était du
conseiller général on avait accès au
préfet et quand on était parlementaire
au ministre
et aujourd'hui les sous-préfectures sont
dévitalisées donc là on a vu aussi suite
au retrait de l'ingénierie de l'État au
service des territoires les départements
ou les grosses intercommunalités il y a
une différence fondamentale entre une
agglo bien structurée bien capée et une
comme-comte de 10 de 15000 20.000
habitants on a vu les départements
prendre la main sur l'ingénierie vous
avez à peu près 80% départements qui ont
des agences techniques des pôles
d'ingénierie des syndicats mixes etc et
puis patatras l'actuel président de la
République dans son premier mandat nous
annonce le grand retour de l'ingénierie
de l'État et ça s'appelle la NCT et dans
son discours de juillet 2018 si j'ai pas
de bêtises il annonce à l'échelle
régionale surprise comme si la région
était le périmètre qu'on parle pas de la
région conseil régional mais le
périmètre des services déconcentrés de
l'État le plus accessible au territoire
et aujourd'hui il faut qu'on clarifie
qu'il s'occupe de l'ingénierie parce que
je pense et je rejoins parfaitement ce
que mon collègue vise présente région a
dit les besoins la surnormalisation les
risques juridiques les besoins des
maires en matière d'ingénierie n'ont
jamais été aussi important deuxième
logique principe de suppléance que les
départements exercent assez souvent
singulièrement dans les domaines santé
sanitaire
l'installation de médecin parfois même
de vétérinaires en zone rurale madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur vous
connaissez assez bien ce genre de
territoire considérant vos départements
d'élection donc j'ai pas besoin de vous
raconter pour la mdvetto aujourd'hui bon
principe de suppliance les départements
se sont eux qui l'appliquent la réalité
c'est que heureusement que les préfets
les préfets sont pas strictosensus dans
l'application de la nôtre
et que ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'espèce de clause de balayage de
compétences générales c'est-à-dire que
quand plus personne s'en occupe c'est en
général au département qu'on confie la
difficulté dans les faits c'est
heureusement beaucoup plus souple que
dans le droit dernier remarque
évidemment qu'on subventionne et qu'on
contrôle actualise avec les territoires
c'est très variable d'un département à
l'autre mais s'il est pas les
subventions d'aide à l'investissement
des départements pour les communes il y
aurait du mal moi la prétention dans mon
département de dire qu'on est le premier
partenaire des communes et des
territoires quand j'additionné les
crédits de paiement d'aide direct aux
communes les contractuations avec les
intercommunalités les subventions au
syndicat technique j'ai pas de problème
pour rivaliser avec la DETR et la DS
donc la vérité c'est que le bailleur de
fond substantiel auprès des communes
singulièrement et aussi parfois des
interconnalités aujourd'hui ça reste
assez souvent le département un
générique soutien financier contractuel
suppléance parfois
rien de neuf par rapport à la
subsidiarité
monsieur le vice-président de joie
je pense je n'oublie pas que je
m'adresse à des parlementaires je pense
qu'il faut faire respirer la relation de
la commune avec son environnement je
m'explique je pense que il faut intégrer
dans la loi les dispositifs permettant
de d'aérer les transferts de compétences
on pourrait très bien imaginer que dans
une agglomération
si la voirie est gérée par le
l'intercommunalité un certain nombre
d'éléments ne le seraient pas ou qu'on
puisse diviser la compétence
conventionnellement entre la commune et
l'intercommunalité je me souviens par
exemple au moment de la création de la
Communauté urbaine de Nantes en 2001
tout le monde s'est aperçu mais juste au
dernier moment que le tourisme était
transféré automatiquement parce qu'il
faisait partie de l'économie en général
aurait personne ni le maire de nom de
l'époque ni les communes autour n'avait
eu envie de le faire sauf qu'ils ont pas
pu faire autrement puisque la loi
imposait se transfert donc il répète un
toilettage à faire dans la loi sur les
sur les compétences elles-mêmes pour
pouvoir réinstaurer au sein de la
commune un certain nombre de pouvoir et
de proximité dans la gestion de tel ou
tel problème ça pourrait y compris
s'appliquer à la collecte des déchets
qui dans les très grandes villes
aujourd'hui pose un certain nombre de
difficultés il suffit de se promener
dans dans certains et puis peut-être
redonner au contrat à la convention
entre commune et
intercommunalité départements ou région
de de l'existence moi je suis assez
partisan du contrat un contrat ça se
discute ça se négocie et puis ça ça
s'exécute et on peut très bien imaginer
entre personnes publiques plus
de contractuel aujourd'hui la loi est
omniprésente elle en sert beaucoup de
choses et ça pose un certain nombre de
difficultés d'ailleurs tout le monde a
vécu l'anecdote d'un maire discutant
avec un président de département ou un
président de Région d'un projet en a
permis ça c'est une excellente idée et
sauf que quand chacun rentre dans son
bureau les administrateurs qui
l'entourent ont très vite comment
dirais-je fait de réduire cette idée
année avant parce qu'elle est pas elle
sorte à telle législation elle sorte à
telle difficulté etc il faudrait
remettre un peu d'air et d'aération dans
tout cela et ça évidemment ça c'est la
responsabilité du législateur et du
gouvernement
pardon pour enfoncer l'idée du contrat
que je partage mais pleinement d'abord
je vais faire une remarque les
collectivités entre elles on sait
contractualisé et notamment
contractualisées ont plus rien dualité
il y a que l'État qui sait pas faire
alors on va mettre de côté le volet
territorial des contrats de plans et les
contrats de plans mais je prends un
exemple très précis excusez-moi je veux
pas parler de l'Allier pour parler de la
vie mais c'est parce que c'est factuel
bien avant les politiques petites villes
de demain le conseil départemental de
l'Allier a créé un dispositif qui
s'appelle reconquête centre-ville centre
bourg
qui s'adresse à toutes les communes le
principe un an d'étude 50 mise en oeuvre
trois piliers non négociables l'habitat
la vitalité le cadre de vie
80% de subventions sur l'étude si c'est
interco qui la porte
30% de subventions sur les 5 ans de
phase projet sur la globalité de
l'enveloppe sur une assiette éligible de
9 millions dont jusqu'à 3 millions de
subventions du Département
et projet par projet on est très libre
de faire les 30%. ce qui permet donc aux
communes d'avoir un le temps mais pas
plus d'un an de la vision stratégique de
leur reconquête de centralité et de la
contractualisation d'appui financier du
Département pour la mettre en œuvre et
l'État il fait quoi
moi j'avais dans mon département la
semaine dernière j'ai accueilli l'ancien
secrétaire d'État la réalité ministre
Giraud dans le cadre d'une mission sur
petite ville de demain avec sa collègue
savoyarde de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
le seul message que j'ai fait passer les
temps encourage PVD mais un peu
d'ingénierie quelques financements par
le biais de la banque des territoires
sauf que quelle commune peut s'engager
dans un programme petite ville de demain
sans avoir une visibilité au moins à
trois ans au moins à 3 ans des moyens
budgétaires qu'elle pourra mobiliser en
termes de subventions en termes de
dépenses donc je rejoins pleinement ce
qui vient d'être dit sur les contrats et
autant les territoires entre nous on
sait faire autant l'État avec les
territoires moi je demande qu'une chose
je vais vous dire très librement moi je
défends avant les questions
décentralisation de différenciation de
tout ce qu'on veut qui sont excusez-moi
d'être un peu trivial du pipeau
je défends une territorialisation des
politiques publiques
on a besoin
de services déconcentré de l'État
efficace et puissant et libre et on a
besoin les collectivités de la même
puissance de la même liberté et laissons
préfet préfet sous préfet sous prétexte
président de département
présentateurs être capable de
territorialiser les politiques publiques
concrètement fongibilité de la dot et de
la des cils
laissons la liberté au préfet en plus
elle contrôle avec des parlementaires
sur la Commission des hauteur de rendre
ces deux enveloppes fongibles s'il y a
des projets sur le territoire qui
justifient d'aller taper un peu sur une
et sur l'autre des enveloppes permettons
préfet préfet de consacrer une quantité
de ces enveloppes pour être capable de
contractualiser avec un territoire s'il
y a des projets qui se régleront pas sur
un ou deux exercices budgétaires
et ça c'est pas des choses que qui
demandent un centime de plus à ce pays
c'est des choses qui demandent juste
comme il y a des lois de programmation y
compris pour les finances publiques
d'avoir une capacité à ce que l'État
décentralisé territoriée puisse aussi
programmer avec le les territoires avec
lequel il est il est en contact donc je
voulais vraiment insister sur ces
logiques de contractualisation parce
qu'elles peuvent porter non seulement
sur un objet mais elles doivent surtout
porter sur des moyens et des ambitions
partagés dans un minimum de durée et
c'est tout à fait faisable j'ajoute
et j'anticipe la question suivante
différenciation etc moi je connais pas
un seul exemple la mise en oeuvre de
cette loi excusez-moi je vais être
provocateur on a dit 3DS on a
différencier etc j'aimerais savoir qui
en France a réussi à le faire alors
peut-être parce que les élus ont pas osé
demander la stricte application de la
loi mais j'ai l'impression qu'on nous a
un peu calmé quand aux tensions postes
ou à notre et qu'en fait aujourd'hui je
vois pas qui est capable de dire ok j'ai
pu véritablement différencier une
politique publique à l'échelle de mon
territoire moi je suis désolé je le vois
pas et je vais prendre un exemple simple
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au
ministre géant
toujours sur la thématique des contrats
et prenons l'exemple des
intercommunalités et prenons par exemple
l'exemple de gemapi est-ce qu'on
pourrait considérer qu'un moment donné
quand vous avez la majorité de qualifiés
vous allez deux tiers ou les moitiés de
population qui dirait dans un
département nous on veut que ça soit le
département qui porte cette compétence
quand bien même la loi nous dit de la
portée que sans avoir besoin d'appliquer
3DS et la différenciation on puisse
avoir un accord local qui dit si une
majorité qualifiée des intercodies c'est
plutôt départementaux alors plutôt
commune c'est pas forcément mon temps
d'appliquer la compétence fustle donnée
par la loi le PCI que tout simplement ça
puisse s'appliquer c'est d'avoir une
capacité de libre administration pas
seulement des collectivités dans
lesquelles nous sions mais de Lead
administration des collectivités entre
elles
et je pense je sais écarté de la copie
de la feuille de Redon excusez je
m'adresse aux collaborateurs mais je
pense que ce sujet-là mérite d'être
pensé complètement de façon nouvelle pas
simplement la libre administration de la
collectivité en tant que telle mais la
libre administration des collectivités
donc en fait à la vérité des territoires
entre eux
là il y a une nouveauté qui donnera de
la souplesse digression qui n'engage que
moi et pas la déesse
moi j'ai toujours regretté le conseiller
territorial
pour au moins une raison et c'est la
seule que je veux développer c'est que
pour la première fois c'était le même
élu qui allait pouvoir décider dans sa
double casquette ce que le département a
les monnaie comme politique
quanticiègent au département est-ce que
la région les monnaies comme politique
anti siègent à la région c'était du
peut-être un peu schizophrène pour une
fois vous pouvez prendre le destin du
partage des compétences en main sans que
ça soit l'état central et la loi qui
impose à chacun toi tu fais ça toi tu
fais ça et j'avais l'habitude de dire le
conseiller territorial il a les pieds
sur terre quand il est conseillé général
et la tête dans les étoiles quand il est
conseillé régional les grands schémas
stratégiques les grandes visions
d'avenir à la région l'opérationnel
concret dans le département mais au
moins au moins c'était le même élu
légitimement désigné par les lecteurs
qui disaient ça on va le faire porter
par le Département ça on va le faire
porter par la région et on aurait
tellement simplifié la question des
compétences croisées enchevêtrée etc etc
parce que là il suffisait de faire
confiance à l'intelligence et
individuelle de ce concier territorial
et collectif des deux assemblées dans
les qualifiées pour à mon avis
fluidifier les relations qu'on pouvait
avoir voilà excusez-moi c'est très
personnel mais je profite de cette
mission pour partager cette réflexion
avec vous
je crois que nos collègues ont des
questions à poser Cécile madame Cécile
cucquier Hermann s'il vous plaît oui
merci pour vos interventions respectives
je ne rouvrirai pas ici le débat sur le
conseiller territorial je pense qu'il
répondait aussi une logique finalement
de renforcer beaucoup plus échelle
intercommunale régionale et européenne
et que finalement je ne suis pas
certaine qui ne finit outre la fusion
des individus et peut-être de la
capacité de d'un peu plus d'agilité les
cheveux de proximité qui est le
département on aurait sorti vraiment
grandi je ferme cette parenthèse mais
nous aurons d'autres occasions pour en
reparler je n'en doute pas voilà
non non pour revenir sur sur le sujet de
la mission et finalement du rapport
parce qu'aujourd'hui les deux
collectivités existent d'ailleurs avec
des modes de scrutin différents ce qui
leur donne aussi je pense d'autres
essences même dans leur propre
fonctionnement et dans leur rapport
au territoire
pour autant vous avez et l'un et l'autre
des compétences qui directement
concernent les communes et le devenir
des communes et quand je parle de
compétences je ne parle même pas de ce
que vous avez évoqué l'un et l'autre des
volontés politiques de faire et qui sont
même si nous critiquons souvent tout de
même encore possible
l'un ayant pour la région l'aménagement
du territoire l'autre ayant pour le
département
cette grande compétence de la solidarité
qui n'est pas que sociale qui est
également territoriale et monsieur le
président du Département le rappelait
tout l'enjeu y compris de la maîtrise de
l'ingénierie territoriale indispensable
pour les communes mais pas seulement
donc moi je voulais vous interroger sur
comment est-ce que l'un et l'autre
vous vivez cette complémentarité et
peut-être que pour le maire d'ailleurs
quoi il me semble en tout cas pour pour
discuter avec ceux de mon département
comment est-ce que l'on
repense des rapports collectivement
mais c'est ce que vous c'est ce qui
était un peu évoqué sur la libre
administration entre collectivités très
certainement qui n'est pas un rapport
entre guillemets de poupée gigogne qui
ferait que il y a la commune le
département la région donc dans un sens
ou dans un autre mais finalement plutôt
un triangle
excusez-moi je je ne dis pas que c'est
intelligent la comparaison que je fais
mais d'un triangle qui fait que infini
tout le monde est lié et finalement pour
un même territoire donné l'on a besoin
alors avec contrat parfois parce que il
y a besoin de visibilité de sécurisation
financière ça nous en sommes je crois
tout d'accord mais au-delà de ça d'une
capacité en tout cas qu'aurait le maire
à aller de l'un à l'autre et de l'autre
Alain beaucoup de façon beaucoup plus
fluide que dans un sentiment un peu
systématique et je ne fais au fond ce à
personne ici mais qui finalement pour
beaucoup de mer et quand c'est pas trop
compliqué j'interpelle mon conseil
départemental parce que malgré tout même
avec les réformes des cantons etc je le
connais encore et en tout cas il est il
est présent chaque week-end je veux dire
ainsi quand c'est un peu plus complexe
où j'ai besoin d'avoir d'un peu plus je
vais aller voir la région et d'ailleurs
parfois même avec une solennité un peu
même si tout ce petit monde on se
connaît et on se voit tous dans les
mêmes lieux mais quand on fait venir le
conseiller régional référente son
territoire il y a je crois voilà je le
dis avec mes mots mais là aussi une
petite solennité supplémentaire comme si
on s'adressait à un échoue au-dessus
alors que infini et on le voit les uns
et les autres et d'ailleurs sans faire
offense on a sur des projets parfois un
financement plus important de la région
parfois plus important du département et
finalement les choses sont beaucoup plus
souples donc voilà j'ai envie de dire
vous comment du côté région comment du
côté département vous vous voyez
justement ces enjeux sur sur les
prochaines années sans revenir sur
biennement tout ce qu'on s'est dit
est-ce que ce que l'on partage
collectivement voilà de la question et
le rapporteur le disait de la nécessité
bien évidemment d'un état aux côtés et
non pas sans soeur pour pour les
communes etc etc parce que je crois que
dans tous les cas d'ailleurs ça n'a
jamais été l'objectif voilà
revitaliser la commune c'est la
revitalisée collectivement dans lequel
chacun contribuera à jouer un rôle et
certainement pas en se disant que les
autres collectivités ne seraient pas
nécessaire justement à cet échelon
démocratique indispensable
on va peut-être enchaîner les questions
avec sénateur Jean-François Rapin
oui merci de vos propos clairs
je vais m'allier à la question de Cécile
que Kerman sur la relation département
région bien sûr en évacuant la question
du conseiller territorial qui
aujourd'hui plus que jamais mon avis
résoudrait pas mal de problèmes
notamment sur la spécificité
on le voit au fil des inaugurations
c'est vrai dans mon département alors je
connais pas forcément les vôtres de
manière pointue mais en tout cas à
chaque inauguration on voit Région
Département état et c'est quasi
systématique sur tous les projets alors
que finalement
la loi nôtre en particulier toutes les
lois de décentralisation avaient
peut-être renforcée
la vision en silo c'est tant mieux c'est
tant mieux pour les communes ceci dit
c'est pas si facile que ça parce que
aujourd'hui pour organiser un projet
dans une commune j'ai été mère longtemps
comme beaucoup d'entre vous mais c'est
encore plus difficile aujourd'hui pour
organiser un projet dans une commune
c'est très compliqué parce que
finalement l'interlocuteur région reste
l'interlocuteur région l'interlocuteur
département reste l'interlocuteur
département et l'interlocuteur à état
permet moi du peu de bien de plus en
plus complexe votre votre affaire de
mutualiser en fait DETR des cils et
aujourd'hui fond vert n'est pas
forcément une très mauvaise idée au
contraire elle serait elle serait
excellente parce que je vois la patate
chaude circuler de DETR à des cils et
puis aujourd'hui à fond vert finalement
à Euro constant
à eurocons et en ayant enlevé en plus la
réserve parlementaire où on n'a jamais
retrouvé nos petits je suis désolé du
peu donc l'idée c'est de dire comment
aujourd'hui on pourrait département
région et état s'il le veut
avoir cette capacité de s'associer
puisque vous le conseiller territorial
existe pas pour faciliter la vie des
mères je parle de là en dépôt de dossier
de subvention par exemple je sais pas si
ça existe des dossiers uniques dans
certaines régions départements si ça
existe c'est vraiment une bonne idée
mais ce serait une bonne idée pour les
élus parce que comme vous le disiez
ligne généri il court après
il y en a plus
mais il faudrait un travail peut-être
commun puisque l’ingénierie elle peut
plus être portée par l'État qu'elle peut
plus être portée séparément par les
régions et par les départements ou quand
elles le sont elles le sont pour leur
propre compte c'est une réflexion qui
permettrait une assistance aux maires
qui soit commune et leur facilité la vie
parce que franchement
ça fait partie des sujets qui nous sont
posés en plus quand on a une
rarification des des fonds des fonds
publics moi j'ai assisté
commission deetr notamment sous
préfecture pour la distribution pour la
distribution des prix dans mon petit
dans l'arrondissement de Montreuil sur
Mer
dans le Pas-de-Calais il y avait 6
millions d'euros de demandes pour 2
millions à servir
d'accord donc vous imaginez la
difficulté qui peut y avoir et là le
sous-préfet voyant qu'il n'avait pas de
fonds dit ben il faudra peut-être voir
avec la région voir avec le département
mais en tout cas
le maire il se retrouve derrière avec 0
DETR et puis vous le savez pour
enclencher des projets aussi bien au
département que la commune on regarde
aussi ce que met l'État et
l'intercommunalité et ça aussi c'est un
sujet donc je crois que la question des
fonds reste prégnante et moi la vraie
question que je vous pose c'est
aujourd'hui est-ce que département et
régions je suis conseiller régional et
ça a été souvent évoqué avec avec mon
président de région sont son temps en
mesure de pouvoir faciliter la vie des
mers sur les dossiers même si au départ
ils n'ont pas les mêmes compétences mais
finalement à l'arrivée on les retrouve
sur des compétences différentes donc on
les retrouve plus sur quoi sur le projet
sur le projet et pas forcément sur leurs
compétences propres
voilà ma question puis dire aussi que on
a quand même fait des erreurs
stratégiques majeures
j'étais au berceau de la politique mais
quand on supprime la data par exemple on
fait pas une bonne affaire
on supprime la data on fait vraiment pas
une bonne affaire et on est en train
dans les régions dans la mienne vous
avez Bertrand recréer une data régionale
en disant voilà c'est ça s'appelle
autrement c'est l'agence prospective
mais au moins on réfléchit un petit peu
sur l'avenir du territoire voilà puis
juste un dernier point aussi c'est sur
la capacité des structures comme le
département et la région a bien
distribuer leur faux nous on a eu des
dispositifs en région de France
qui était centré sur les
intercommunalités en disant aux interco
bah finalement choisissez les projets
dans les communes et on s'est rendu
compte que finalement c'était les
présidents d'Interco qui tiraient tout
pour eux et ça a été un vrai souci et là
on a revu un dispositif qui s'adresse à
la fois aux Indes aux communes aux
interco et au très grands projets voilà
c'est une petite expérience mais aussi
la question sur des départements région
je pense qu'on aurait tout à gagner pour
les élus pour les mers à les faire
collaborer
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
monsieur de joie vous souhaitez répondre
répondre ou effectivement exprimer un
avis à la suite des deux interventions
sur la première
et effectivement il faut il faut jamais
oublier que la commune c'est quand même
le lieu physique où tout arrive et tout
se résout les dossiers sont dans une
commune donc ça lui donnera toujours un
statut particulier par rapport au
département par rapport à la région
et puis pour le partage des compétences
madame évoquait le social c'est vrai
qu'à la région par exemple c'est un
domaine où nous on a mis en place une
politique handicap mais c'est quand même
un domaine où on est extrêmement peu
présent et quelquefois on se fait
interpeller par exemple au Césaire le
conseiller économique et social
environnemental régional ou les
représentants des associations
de la solidarité nous incite nous
demande d'intervenir dans ce domaine
alors que effectivement c'est pas
vraiment de l'autre alors est-ce qu'il
faut qu'on soit qu'on rétablisse des
clauses de compétences générales moi je
ne le crois pas je crois qu'il est pas
mauvais
cueillir encore quand même des
compétences par niveau de collectivité
même s'il faut aérer comme je le disais
tout à l'heure l'ensemble sur
l'ingénierie je partage les
préoccupations de tout le monde en
matière de fonds européens nous avons
l'obligation en général à l'intérieur
d'une enveloppe pour un projet dans
dédié une partie à l'ingénierie du
projet y compris dans la commune ou le
l'intercommunalité destinataire de du
fédère ou du FEDER etc donc ça pourrait
être également quelque chose à
insérer ou à prévoir que l'ingénierie
que les communes puissent bénéficier
d'un service d'ingénierie qui leur
serait totalement dédié alors
on les modalités je sais pas
suffisamment compétent où je manque de
temps pour le développer mais ça
pourrait être intéressant parce que
c'est vrai que pour les communes y
compris les plus petites ça c'est un
c'est un vrai sujet
ce président oui avec plaisir beaucoup
de choses ont été partagées qui sont
passionnantes
d'abord je note avec plaisir sénateur
que finalement dans vos propos ce qui
est essentiel avoir disparu depuis la
loi de l'autre les finances prend
croisées les revenus d'une actualité
quotidienne totalement
admise et à la limite je m'en réjouis
c'est la triste qu'il y a même c'est un
peu le sens aussi de ce que vous disiez
sur où est-ce qu'on va taper pour avoir
les sous mais je rappelle juste la loi
nôtre et la suppression des clones
générale de compétences était censé
faire voler en éclat le millefeuille et
notamment les financements croisés et
qu'aujourd'hui astucieusement les uns et
les autres qu'on soit demandeur ou qu'on
soit contributeur la vérité c'est qu'on
s'est débrouillé pour surtout faire qu'à
partir de dorénavant ça soit comme
auparavant et je pense
je me permets mais comme vous le disiez
très bien on peut faire la loi mais la
loi de finances est aussi des fois une
vérité qui a encouragé à faire surtout
bien comme avant pour continuer de mener
les projets je suis bien d'accord mais
c'est un point qui me paraît important
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait aujourd'hui
sache que plus personne l'histoire des
financements croisés tout compte fait
tout compte fait donc ça mérite
peut-être pour le coup sans parler du
rétablissement stricto-sensuit de la
clause générale de compétences mais de
refaire un point d'actualité qui dit
2015 2023 il a fallu moins de 8 ans pour
se rendre compte que cette idée de
cesser les financements croisés n'a
aucun sens la preuve c'est qu'on
n'applique pas
deuxième remarque
bon moi j'ai un problème avec mais ça
c'est très personnel enfin c'est très
personnellement parce que je crois que
j'ai réussi à peu près convaincre le
Président de DF j'assume d'être d'avoir
une sensibilité politique moi j'ai un
gros problème avec la notion de chef de
fila pour moi le chef de fila c'est un
concept pur produit de la loi nôtre qui
est la pilule qui devait nous faire
passer justement la suppression de la
clause générale de compétences donc
aujourd'hui soit je préfère si on veut
être techno comparent de
d'autorité organisatrice de ce qui
existe pour les transports pour d'autres
sujets soit comme le dit François
sauvadé qu'on parle de pilotage et de
pilotes mais moi j'ai en travers de la
gorge cette notion de chef de fil et
chef de fila qui en fait la vérité ne
veut rien dire parce que soit on est
compétences on n'est pas compétent et si
on revient à ce que j'ai trouvé
passionnant tout à l'heure cette idée de
faire contractualiser davantage les
territoires et l'État entre eux la
question de savoir qui est le chef de
film ou l'ensemble y est ou le pilote
c'est plus le sujet c'est l'intelligence
qui primera
troisième remarque sénatrice
je suis complètement d'accord avec
l'image du triangle mais c'est pas le
triangle en mode hiérarchique c'est les
bases de la pyramide et c'est une
pyramide à trois faces et elle a une
assise et elle a trois faces et on n'est
pas de savoir si effectivement sauf dans
la présence des discours quand il faut
couper le ruban il y a un rampe
protocolaire on est effectivement sur
qui va être le plus à même de pouvoir
aider de pouvoir accompagner et je crois
que ça dépend la vérité de la taille des
projets pour financer 300 mètres de
voirie communale il y a pas besoin que
la région aille dans cette
granuleométrie là le département est
capable de le faire en revanche si c'est
pour refaire un centre aqualudique ou
une piscine qui va rayonner au-delà d'un
collège et d'un lycée c'est bien que la
région soit particulièrement généreuse
pour structurer le territoire et donc
l'offre éducative qui permettra aux
enfants du collège ou du lycée de savoir
nager d'être autonome pour prendre des
exemples concrets par contre je note
rappelons-nous juste le excusez-moi je
vais être trivial je vous prie m'excuse
dans cet enceinte le merdier de la
séquence électorale 14 15
pour montrer à quel point il est
important qu'on soit coordonné 2014
c'est l'année où je suis allumé je place
le premier adjoint amer mars les
élections sont finies
et il ne se passe plus rien on se dit
maintenant faut qu'on attende quel sera
de nouvelles politiques du conseil
général qui allait devenir départemental
donc on a attendu mars 2015 donc au
niveau des communes entre mars 2014 et
mars 2015 on attendait que la séquence
départementale soit faite et si tôt que
la séquence départementale de mars 2015
est passé on se dit oui mais maintenant
la région va décider quoi et là pas de
bol c'était décembre de la même année et
donc on a encore attendu la fin de
l'année 2015 et la vérité c'est que les
régions avaient pas forcément tout au
1er janvier les choses complètement
claires donc en fait il a fallu attendre
la fin du premier semestre 2000 16 pour
qu'on ait vraiment la visibilité à tous
les niveaux les axes prioritaires et
stratégiques des régions les axes
stratégiques des départements et les
communes qui munissent dans la semoule
en attendant que les partenaires
notamment financiers soit dans les soit
dans les starting blocks
moi c'était une très mauvaise expérience
cette année-là enfin cette séquence là
je note que 20 21 ça a été plus fluide
qu'on a moins perdu de temps
parce que tout le monde a revoté pour ce
qui connaissait ce qui était rassurant
et ça pas été un vote politique au sens
classique ça a été un vote j'ai besoin
de repères et au moins je sais ce que
j'ai bon mais je vous dis pas qu'il faut
aller vers une logique de mythermes
comme aux États-Unis et d'avoir un
groupement du bloc des élections locales
j'irai pas jusque là par contre
j'observe que la bonne articulation dont
la commune reste encore une fois on
revient pas sur ce qu'on a dit l'élément
de première approche de premier rang de
premier guichet quand les échelons
partenaires pour par dire surprend ce
que je voudrais pas être en
contradiction avec notre échange avec la
quand les échelons partenaires ne sont
pas calés ça ralentit
autrement dit la commune est l'interpo
peut pas avancer si c'est pas clair
illisible au moins du côté du
département et de la région et qu'on a à
défaut d'avoir intérêt à faire une seule
séquence électorale le même jour au
moins à éviter les distorsions
de temps entre la séquence municipale et
les séquences départementales et
régionales dernière chose
je vais défendre dans toute cette
organisation évidemment quelque chose
qui est un plaidoyer pro de mots
département de France revendique que les
départements pourraient davantage la
collectivité des réseaux
des infrastructures
les routes le débit pourquoi pas les
ordures les réseaux les infrastructures
et à ce titre là la commune doit rester
le lieu du service
les politiques servicielles les services
des familles les services des personnes
en situation de fragilité ce qui nous
enlèvera pas au département d'acheter
pleinement notre rôle notamment de
financeurs des is mais autant je crois
que la commune ne pourra jamais être
supplée par qui que ce soit quand il
s'agit des services au quotidien auprès
des populations autant peut-être vu la
complexité les coûts et la technicité
parfois des infrastructures stratégiques
les réseaux pourraient revenir au
département et j'arrêterai là-dessus sur
cette prise de parole là j'observe par
paradoxalement deux choses que la seule
strate gagne garder la clause générale
de compétences et celle qui parfois
budgétairement je pense régulièrement
commune à caractère rural et la plus
fragile
c'est elle qui a le droit de tout faire
dans tout mais qui a pas les latitudes
et les moyens de pouvoir assumer cette
liberté donnée et deuxième chose
aujourd'hui quand je vous parle de
politique des réseaux départements
politiques cerviciels aux communes qui
se débrouillant avec leur
intercommunalité je suis de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut redonner du sens à
aller au chef-lieu
mes chefs-lieux et qu'aujourd'hui si il
y a repensé le rôle du maire et de la
commune je crois qu'on ferait part en
fait j'en fais une suggestion présidente
rapporteur sénatrice et sénateurs j'en
fais une suggestion
l'intercommunalité ne remplacera jamais
ce rôle particulier du chef-lieu dans la
proximité jamais
il y a des communes qui nous rend jamais
multiservices pour assurer les gens sur
le quotidien
santé commerce administration et autres
et je pense que si on doit profiter à
un type de commune plus particuliers
c'est celui-ci
c'est la commune qui assure un peu plus
de centralité toute proportion dans son
environnement
je pourrais balayer les exemples est-ce
qu'il y a un collège ou un lycée est-ce
qu'il y a une piscine est-ce qu'il y a
des infrastructures sportives de qualité
une couverte et une ouverte est-ce qu'un
pool de culture animation exposition
multimédia qui soit pas qu'une
bibliothèque est-ce qu'il y a une maison
pluridiscipline notre santé est-ce qu'il
y a un marché couvert ou une halle
couverte ou une logique de marché
au-delà du commerce quotidien qui permet
d'avoir notamment sur les circuits
courts les protéger alimentaire
territoriaux etc une concentration et je
pourrais vous faire la liste en fait
c'est un dispositif que je réfléchis au
niveau du département
mais je le partage avec vous moi j'ai
contractualiser avec ces chefs-lieux
pour leur dire schéma départemental
d'accessibilité des services au public
c'est 20 minutes il faut qu'on fasse
mieux on doit tomber au quart d'heure
on doit tomber au quart d'heure et
qu'aujourd'hui la France et la
République restera une et indivisible
avec des différences la commune de 150
habitants aura pas tout ça mais pourvu
qu'à moins de 15 minutes on est garanti
un minima de ce que j'appelle le service
ciel auprès de nos populations je pense
qu'on aura déjà je vous parle très
librement c'est natrice et sénateurs
apporter une réponse au moment des
gilets jaunes
apporter une réponse à ceux que
j'appelle les fâchés qui ne sont pas des
fachos et apporter une réponse à cette
rupture territoriale de notre pays dans
lequel quel que soit les meilleures
volontés possibles de la région des
départements si aujourd'hui c'est
commune n'apporte pas la satisfaction
première aux populations au moins dans
un bassin de proximité il faudra passer
donner demain qu'on aura des crispations
encore plus profondes
peut-être un mot des gens en réaction
aux propos que vous avez tenu sur la
territorialisation de l'action publique
je crois que
sans trop avancer on peut dire que c'est
en tout état de cause la philosophie que
nous avons tenté de porter sur un texte
qui est selon nous largement inaboutique
et le fameux Text3 3DS je vous rappelle
que le Sénat avait porté notamment la
gestion différenciée des compétences au
sein de l'intercommunalité le tout pour
avoir le maximum d'agilité convaincu
qu'il appartient aux élus de savoir ce
qui est bon tout simplement pour leur
territoire mais là-dessus je fais bien
les propos que vous avez tenus
idem sur la question des enveloppes de
l'État moi je suis plus loin que vous je
pense qu'il faut pas que ce soit le
préfet qui aille piocher il faut fondre
ces dispositifs il faut faire à
l'échelon des départements des pactes au
niveau de l'État ce qui a pu être fait
dans certains départements qui
connaissent des difficultés profondes je
pense notamment aux Ardennes mais la
réalité elle est elle est évidente
pardon de le dire je parle de la loi 3DS
il a fallu se battre comme jamais ici
même au Sénat pour que à la fin des fins
après moules de négociation nous
arrivions à ce que le préfet de
département puisse notifier la des cils
mais ça a été une faculté soumise à
l'autorisation du préfet de région vous
imaginez où on en est la réalité elle
est toute autre c'est exactement comme
les financements croisés les
financements croisés le paradoxe c'est
que c'est aujourd'hui l'État qui les
appelle de ses vœux puisque il n'est pas
un sous-préfet qui avant de notifié ces
enveloppes de DETR ne fassent pas le
tour du département et de la région pour
savoir singulièrement dans un temps de
relance si on ne va pas
malheureusement mettre à mal la
consommation ou devoir rendre
temporairement parce qu'ils sont
réaffectés ensuite mais certains crédits
donc je crois que tout ça est une vaste
disons les choses très clairement une
vaste hypocrisie la finalité par rapport
à notre mission c'est que la variable
d'ajustement c'est toujours le maire et
la proximité voir le département et là
et la région bien sûr non non mais en ce
qui concerne notre champ d'études le
maire se retrouve pris en otage et la
réalité c'est que s'agissant des
dotations
la réalité c'est que on parlait tout à
l'heure de la question de l'eau
aujourd'hui puisque les agences de l'eau
ont décidé de ne plus financer les
communes isolées c'est très souvent les
départements qui vont et c'est parfois
c'est le cas dans mon département de
l'Ardèche la DETR qui prend à sa charge
des crédits qui ne sont plus assumés par
par les agences de l'eau donc on voit
bien que tout ça finalement mériterait
d'être largement
revisité moi la vraie question qui se
pose c'est fort du constat que nous
sommes en train d'opérer c'est à dire
que rien ne se fera demain sans
l'accompagnement
par les départements et par les régions
de la strat communale voire
intercommunale la vraie difficulté c'est
que les différentes évolutions en
matière de fiscalité ont mis à mal et on
le part en l'évoquait avec le président
sauvadé mais on n'ose pas imaginer ce
qui malheureusement risque d'arriver une
chute des DMTO parce que les ressources
des département se verrait
particulièrement affecter et donc
l'investissement parce que la grande
différence pour moi et je le dis très
clairement
sans emballage la véritable différence
entre l'ingénierie qui peut être fait
par la région et le département ou
l'ingénierie qui est fait par l'État
petite vie de demain action coeur de
ville c'est qu'on pense l'ingénierie on
pense le projet mais derrière fermer le
Mans il y a plus de financement si ce
n'est episodiquement un peu de DETR mais
rien ne se fait action cœur de ville
rien ne se fait sans les collectivités
et c'est quand même un véritable
problème dans l'approche qu'on peut
avoir de l'ingénierie mais une ingénerie
qui a vocation a déclenché du
financement derrière et donc mon propos
et on le voit d'ores et déjà c'est que
vous avez entre 15 et 20 départements
aujourd'hui qui sont dans des situations
financières qui les empêchent finalement
de faire cet accompagnement qu'on aura
peut-être demain des scénarios assez
identiques s'agissant des régions si on
ne pense pas cette question de la
péréquation et ça c'est une question que
je vous pose à tous les deux c'est
comment vous voyez parce que vous avez
fait référence tout à l'heure au
discours du président président de la
République moi j'ai le souvenir du
lancement ici même au Sénat en juillet
2017 de la Conférence nationale des
territoires qui avait une des vocation
c'était de penser la péréquation faire
en sorte que justement on puisse avoir
une péréquation au-delà de ça on n'a pas
eu de péréquation on a eu les contrats
de Cahors c'était pas nécessairement ce
à quoi nous attendions ni ce à quoi nous
nous aspirerons donc c'est demain quel
péréquation et encore une fois moi je
reviens à la question initiale mais si
on veut faire en sorte que et vous
l'avez fort justement dit on est une
territorialisation de l'action publique
et c'est peut-être la seule bémol que je
mets par rapport aux propos c'est que
pour moi la déconcentration elle a un
sens profond c'est qu'aujourd'hui on le
voit bien le schisme dans la
territorialisation c'est qu'on a très
souvent une déconcentration qui n'est
pas aboutie parce que vous avez à juste
titre rappeler le rôle essentiel des
sous-préfectures quand je vois et je le
dis qu'on réouvre nous étions dans la
somme des sous-préfectures sans y mettre
de humain sans y mettre de personnel
vous ferez absolument rien avec cette
forme là de la déconcentration une
déconcentration qui est obligé
systématiquement de se référer à
l'échelon des directions régionales de
l'État donc on voit bien l'inertie face
à un besoin d'agilité des collectivités
et particulièrement des mers et on l'a
vu à l'occasion de la crise sanitaire et
du covid on a besoin d'avoir une
réactivité très forte on l'a du côté des
collectivités on l'a trop peu souvent
vis-à-vis de l'État dès lors que ce sont
des décisions qui échappent au préfet de
département ou sous-préfet et qui
renvoie à un périmètre de l'action
publique des services déconcentrés de
l'État qui échappent au périmètre
départemental donc encore une fois on
voit bien et c'est pourquoi moi
j'aimerais bien avoir votre vision sur
péréquation et ce besoin si on veut
véritablement avoir une action je veux
dire
déconcentrer ou en tout cas
territorialisé d'avoir j'allais dire
peut-être une nouvelle étape de
déconcentration accompagner d'un
réarmement de l'État territorial
singulièrement dans les sous-préfectures
le vice-président voulait répondre
une équation
moi je suis pas du tout opposé à cette
idée de péréquation puisque je veux dire
l'unité de la République de la nation
nécessite effectivement que on puisse
travailler extrêmement bien sur sur
cette question mais moi je vais même un
peu un peu plus loin parce que nous
sommes confrontés alors c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être une particularité dans
l'ouest de la France
à ce que les dotations
quelles qu'elles soient qui nous sont
accordées les bases qui permettent les
calculs etc sont souvent faibles pour
des raisons qu'on arrive jamais à
comprendre et si on pouvait avoir du
côté du ministère des Finances une
meilleure lisibilité sur les calculs de
toutes les sommes que l'État
attribuent dans les territoires quand il
s'agit de Somme qui sont calculées avec
des bases et des coefficients je parle
pas des des autres sommes qui sont
accordées sur un projet particulièrement
et bien ce serait extrêmement
intéressant d'avoir une meilleure
transparence sur tous ces tous ces
véhicule tous ces calculs là après pour
la péréquation effectivement le problème
est de trouver les bons périmètres pour
l'appliquer et de bien se mettre
d'accord et là aussi que les discussions
entre ceux qui sont partis à la
péréquation
puisse s'imposer à l'état moi j'ai le
souvenir il n'y a pas si longtemps que
cela que les régions au sein de région
de France toutes les régions c'était
mises d'accord sur un système de
péréquation qui permettait notamment à
ma région auprès de la loi d'être plus
avantagé sur une certaine politique et
une certaine somme et malheureusement le
ministère des Finances n'a jamais
accepté la corinanime des 13 régions sur
cette péréquation que nous avions
modifié ensemble
donc ça reste toujours soumis à
l'autorité de l'État
et du ministère des Finances d'ailleurs
ce président
en fait sénateur n'est pas forcément
d'accord sur
la structuration des services des
concentrés de l'État tel que vous voulez
de l'évoquer dans les préférences je
vous raconte une anecdote je suis obligé
de faire son nom parce qu'elle est
encore l'exercice une préfète de
l'Allier on évoquait la question des
pouvoirs des directions régionales
sur un sujet qui concernait le
département de la ville elle me dit
monsieur le Président j'ai l'arme
atomique
la délégation de signature et alors
n'oubliez pas monsieur le Président que
les directions régionales non pouvoir
dans mon département que par délégation
de signature du préfet de département et
moi j'avoue que je pensais que les
directions régionales relevées de
l'autorité directe des préfets de région
j'ignorais cette disposition
particulière que le préfet département
donne des délégations de signatures à
l'agréable
peu importe
peut-être qu'il suffirait de rappeler ça
à chaque préfet département déjà
aujourd'hui tout de suite ça demande pas
un texte de loi pas une cavalier pas un
amendement
que chaque préfet de département a donné
délégation de signature aux Directions
Régionales de l'État et qu'elles ne
peuvent intervenir que parce que il ou
elle a bien voulu le faire
péréquation
qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste à péricauer
les départements dont on a fait le
boulot entre nous les le font de 1,6
milliards d'euros des droits de mutation
en péréquation horizontale décider et
disposés par les départements entre les
très très riches simplement grosso modo
les départements qui ont un littoral et
il est très très pauvres ceux qui sont
mieux tout le reste donc nous on a déjà
fait la péréquation horizontale entre
départements sur les dmteo un milliard 6
ça n'est pas rien
mais pour parler de péréquation qu'en
faut-il avoir des points de recettes
comparables
on perdrait quoi la fraction de TVA
moi je vais être excusez-moi j'allume
les gyrophares
je me lâcher
je vous causer 30 secondes la fraction
de thé vert en 2022 ma notification
définitive ma fraction de TVA qui
remplace mon foncier bâti je l'ai reçu
aucun octobre
si on veut soutenir l'investissement
local c'est trop tard au mois d'octobre
pour lancer des marchés et pour pouvoir
exécuter la commande publique
et puis je viens de recevoir là un
courrier qui me dit tout compte fait
c'était un peu surévalué votre deuxième
couche d'octobre il y avait 900 000 de
trop donc on va vous les corriger sur la
fraction de TVA 2023 non mais on est où
les départements n'ont plus aucun
pouvoir de recettes on est 100%
tributaire des dotations de l'État et il
le dit état nous dit bon ben on Mars
Avril je vais dire à peu près ce que tu
auras mais tu seras vraiment sûr qu'en
octobre mais c'est pas exclure quand
janvier d'après je te dis ce que je t'en
ai trop filé non mais c'est quoi ça on
est où
et par contre quand j'ai un contrôle de
la Chambre régionale des comptes c'est
ce qui était le cas ces derniers temps
quelle est la première chose qu'on me
demande où est votre PPI ou être votre
PPF
mais moi j'ai dit au magistrat mais
qu'est-ce que les que je vous fasse
comme plan plus réel de quoi que ce soit
je sais même pas je sais même pas au
début du 4e trimestre de l'année combien
j'aurais réellement d'argent ou pas
dépensé
alors sénateur j'aimerais qu'on parle de
peréquation pour de vrai qu'on commence
déjà par parler de stabilité
deuxième chose j'ai annoncé la couleur
je vais être désagréable
allez comparer le budget de toutes les
régions de France
au budget du plus gros département du
périmètre régional ou de la plus grosse
métropole
après avoir défalquer les fonds
européens
voilà
alors effectivement le budget des
régions est pas un budget qui est marqué
par une rigidité de la dépense
contrairement au budget des départements
quand on a payé les solidarités humaines
on est quasiment à 60% de rigidité
personnelle compris
les régions ont beaucoup plus de
souplesse budgétaires mais excusez-moi
chers collègues conseillère et
conseiller régionaux
je vais parler du passé comme ça ça je
crois qu'à personne dans le temps la
région Vergne avait pas de force de
frappe budgétaire plus forte que le
département du Puy-de-Dôme
je pense que sur notre région puisqu'on
est au moins trois en être si on compare
le budget de la région 4 milliards mais
il faut retraiter les fonds européens à
la métropole de Lyon ou au conseil
départemental de de l'Isère je pense que
la force de frappe elle est kif-kif
si vous prenez les Alpes-Maritimes et la
métropole d'Aix-Marseille par rapport à
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur bon donc on
va juste reposer les choses la réalité
c'est que le budget des départements des
métropoles ou des régions quand il
s'agit de puissantes métropoles ou
puissants ça se tient
excusez-moi d'être un peu indélicat mais
il faut rappeler les choses de même que
quand on parlait de fiscalité je batte
ma coule pas la vérité c'est quand on
avait une fiscalité avec une autonomie
on était sur la marge d'ajustement on
n'a jamais eu le lever les impôts pour
aller chercher 30-45 ans ou 60 millions
d'euros pour faire des projets
c'était pour aller chercher de trois
quatre cinq millions histoire
d'équilibré de boucler les choses sans
dégrader l'épargne donc je suis pas en
train je suis pas en train de vous dire
que je pars retrouver une capacité
fiscalité mais je suis en train de dire
qu'il faut pas non plus qu'on exagère
les élus locaux notre fiscalité servait
pas à aller chercher des dizaines ou des
centaines de milliers d'euros elle
cherchait à faire les marges d'équilibre
bon
quand j'ai dit ça
faut peut-être nous simplifier les
lignes de recettes moi je sais même plus
combien j'ai de recettes différentes
dans mon budget département parce que
tous ces empilés a été bricolé au fil
des compensations des accords de
Matignon sur les is des modifications de
fiscalité de 6 dessins enfin on devrait
avoir un absolu 3 lignes une dotation de
fonctionnement une dotation liée au
compensation des politiques qu'on assume
pour le compte de l'État que ce soit les
communes comme les départements les
solidarités pour les uns et les
proximités de service public pour les
autres et puis une dotation
d'investissement et effectivement une
capacité d'autonomie budgétaire après
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas normal que
j'ai 7 ou 8 lignes un bout de test ca la
TSCA pompier de la TSCA décentralisation
d'adgf du signe du ça c'est hallucinant
enfin si on n'a pas fait inspecteur
général des finances on sait plus qui
brille le budget d'une collectivité
quand est-ce qu'on d'État français se
donne pardon quand est-ce que la
République française parce que étant de
l'Allier l'État français sens
particulier chez nous quand est-ce que
la République française
sera simplement capable de redonner à
ces collectivités un principe de
confiance
comme l'état fédéral allemand
sont pas tous égaux
les budgets en Allemagne sont pas
exactement les mêmes la distorsion elle
existe sauf qu'à ma connaissance quand
un territoire dit là j'ai besoin et
qu'il se tourne vers l'état fédéral il a
une réponse crédible et de confiance
aujourd'hui c'est un des problèmes de
notre pays quand une commune se retrouve
vraiment face à une difficulté ou alors
par rapport à un projet qui sort de
l'ordinaire
idem pour un département pour une région
et qu'elle frappe à l'apport de l'étang
disant là c'est pas que je viens vous
habituer c'est pas pour payer là il y a
vraiment besoin est-ce qu'il y a une
réponse mais jamais
retrouvons déjà ce principe même de
confiance entre les territoires et la
République
et je termine pardon parce que j'étais
très long mais je vais aller jusque
jusqu'au bout de ce sujet là
philosophie de l'impôt
moi je suis malheureux de penser que
dans notre pays se débat est totalement
escamoté et qu'il n'a jamais lieu
singulièrement au moment des élections
présidentielles etatives c'est quoi la
philosophie de l'impôt sur lequel
aujourd'hui le peuple français est prêt
à donner mandat et adhérer
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est un impôt
qu'il y ait au revenu notamment du
travail ou de quelques placements
la TVA c'est un épaule sur la
consommation ça dépend de ce que je sors
de mon porte-monnaie les droits de
mutation c'est un impôt sur la
constitution du patrimoine
le foncier baptiste est strictement n'en
peut patrimonial
quand est-ce qu'on repose pour de vrai
dans ce pays la philosophie même de
ontxe quoi et accessoirement pour
financer quoi
parce que c'est bien beau de dire on
supprime la TH puis on pique le foncier
bâti département pour le Finot commune
puis alors un coup de TVA mais la TVA
elle est inodore et incolore personne
sait quand il fait ses courses combien
il a payé en euros absolu de TVA pour
remplir les caisses de l'État et une
partie de l'Europe
le foncier bâti on paye quand on reçoit
sa feuille comme les ordures ménagères
la redevance en fléchés mais voyez et ce
mode d'insister la philosophie de
l'impôt aujourd'hui on considère
qu'est-ce qui doit être taxé les revenus
la consommation l'accession patrimoine
le patrimoine existant
et je pense que c'est quand on aura
répondu à cette question qu'on pourra de
nouveau répondre à la question d'une
autonomie excusez-moi cette longue
réponse ou de la péréquation sénateur
entre les collectivités parce que si je
suis sur un impôt physique évidemment
j'ai une distorsion d'un territoire à
l'autre
mes bases et mes flux de droit de
mutation ou de fonciers bâties au sens
large sont pas les mêmes d'une commune
ou d'un département à l'autre si je suis
sur la consommation c'est la même chose
donc elle ne peut être que nationale
si vous comparez le produit Teva du
département de l'Allier ou département
du Rhône ou de l'Ardèche ou à quelques
quelques départements mais c'est déjà
Pérou
la consommation dans ces territoires là
elle a rien à voir avec la consommation
dans un département rural donc la
question de la péréquation excusez-moi
mais c'est une non question puisque
c'est déjà par nature un produit de
fiscalité qui de toute façon n'est pas
égal d'un territoire à un autre mais pas
plus que les droits de mutation pas plus
que le foncier bâti
donc je reprends le problème
différemment est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
une péricquation ou est-ce qu'il faut
repenser sur les besoins normaux pour
que des politiques publiques soient
conduites celles qui relève de la
République et une indivisible sur
l'ensemble du territoire national y
compris le tramarin on n'a pas parlé
parce qu'on est des métropolitains et
celles qui relèvent de la volonté
politique des territoires à prendre leur
avenir en main
dernière remarque
sauf erreur de ma part on n'a jamais
autant prélevé d'argent dans ce pays et
on n'a jamais autant dépensé d'argent
public historiquement comme une
intercommunalité département région
agence de l'État état
et je crois où j'ai le sentiment qu'on
n'a jamais autant d'insatisfaction de la
part des Françaises et des Français par
rapport au service public et au service
rendu au public comment est-ce qu'on en
est arrivé là
moi j'ai pas vu les budgets ni des
collectivités de l'État être en
décroissance ces dernières années ils
sont toujours globalement d'augmentation
on a rajouté des strates on a rajouté
des prélèvements a priori en dépense
tout ce qu'on reçoit je vais pas le
sentiment non plus qu'on capitalise et
compte thésaurise et jamais on a eu
autant d'insatisfaction
donc
je me lâche mais c'est pas la
péréquation au sujet aujourd'hui
parce que péricouis toutes les recettes
de produits sont par définition
inégalitaire d'un territoire à l'autre
par définition
sauf si on me donne la bonne fiscalité
dont on est certain qu'elle est en juste
proportion parfaitement justement
ajustée au territoire la bonne assiette
qui ferait que d'un territoire à l'autre
personne ne puisse dire ouais c'est
anormal
je reformule comme ça la question de
péréquation le jour on a une fiscalité
ou un produit dont chaque territoire
quand je dis territoire c'est aussi une
commune qu'un département qu'une région
peut dire ouais ça c'est juste ça
correspond bien à ce qu'il faut sauf à
trouver ça la péréquation en fait est un
sujet permanent
porter un débat et après on pourra
en discuter pendant très longtemps vous
avez pris l'exemple de l'Allemagne
exemple très intéressant la Bavière
qui produit une richesse c'est plusieurs
milliards qui sont péricway sur le
nombre de Berlin chaque année
vous avez pas de la métropole de Lyon et
c'est trois milliards 9 de budget on
peut faire ce qu'on veut et dire ce
qu'on veut malgré tous les efforts et on
les on y assiste on les voit et on les
souligne d'un département comme l'Allier
vis-à-vis du développement économique
peut-être plus important encore que
d'autres départements de cette région
qu'on se
profile et cette sociologie rurale pour
partie on voit bien on n'arrivera jamais
à générer et donc pour moi la
péréquation c'est aussi demain de
s'interroger si là où on produit moi je
parle même pas de d'impôts au niveau
national et de redistribution je dis
qu'à un moment donné je prends un
exemple sur la question du versement
mobilité par exemple
quand on voit aujourd'hui que la
métropole de Lyon justement c'est elle
qui perçoit ce versement et que Lyon si
on compare par exemple à Marseille qui
est un territoire beaucoup plus
important
aujourd'hui quel est le phénomène qui
permet de se dire que Lyon parce que si
on se borne à la métropole de Lyon
forcément on n'arrive pas à trouver dire
les ressources humaines nécessaires pour
faire fonctionner pour répondre aux
besoins en matière de développement
économique donc il faut aller chercher
plus loin peut-être même dans l'Allier
peut-être en Ardèche assurément dans la
Loire en Isère et donc il faut bien
penser les transports à une échelle qui
est supra
métropolitaine et donc c'est ce que
j'appelle aussi une forme de péréquation
oui on est d'accord on est d'accord et
c'est bien là où je pense que
la péréquation elle se ponce aussi vous
avez parlé territorialisation de
l'action publique elle se pense aussi et
là ça nous ramène à l'objet de notre
étude qui est celle des des communes à
l'échelle des territoires parce que
sinon j'ai peur malheureusement et je
faisais référence et écho tout à l'heure
au 15 ou 20 départements qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans des situations
budgétaires assez
exemples on dira qui n'ont pas les
capacités de porter cette forme de parce
que à l'époque il y a 30 ans ou 40 ans
la péréquation elle était pensée à
l'échelle départementale essentiellement
essentiellement
pour partie quand le département à la
capacité
d'opérer voilà donc c'est cette
péréquation moi que j'ai évoqué c'est à
dire comment à l'échelle d'un territoire
pas nécessairement repensant par le
niveau ou le National donc c'est à dire
supra territorial on arrive à penser les
territoires c'est l'exemple des des
pactes entre métropoles et territoires
qui sont mis en place et dont on voit on
en parlait la dernière fois à Toulouse
qu'ils sont pour partir efficaces mais
pour une grande partie j'allais dire
assis sur des choses assez cosmétiques
et qu'il va falloir quand même que ces
mannes là elle puisse irriguer quand on
parle du ruissellement on sait très bien
que ça se fait pas tout à fait
naturellement on a beaucoup travaillé
sur la métropole de Clermont par exemple
dès lors qu'on est en dehors ou dans la
métropole on n'a pas nécessairement le
même accompagnement alors bien sûr si on
rapporte à l'individu aux résidents aux
citoyens mais quand on parle
d'investissement public là la relation
est assez différente quoi et la
métropole pour moi en tout cas elle doit
irriguer un peu son son territoire
l'interlande ou le territoire
interstitiel
très bien merci est-ce que vous avez
d'autres points à rajouter ou nous avons
fait le tour
non mais c'est c'était très très
intéressant et pour nous pour nous
essentiels on partage bien sûr vos
constats une grande partie de vos
constats et de vos analyses et en tout
cas vous avez répondu aussi au
à cette question de l'importance du trio
départements région commune et de toutes
ces interactions que ces trois
collectivités peuvent avoir dans bien
sûr l'accompagnement de la commune au
premier chef mais aussi la vitalité de
nos territoires et je dirais le
développement aussi en termes d'emploi
de
d'économie générer toute cette économie
parce que quand le département comme
suit des Hautes-Pyrénées que je connais
bien amen près de 10 millions d'euros de
subventions à des collectivités que sont
les communes au premier chef c'est
derrière tu de 25 à millions d'euros qui
sont dépensés dans l'économie locale en
circuit court avec nos artisans avec nos
entreprises et ça c'est essentiel aussi
pour la vitalité des territoires sur sur
les crédits croisés je dirais juste que
l'État a eu du mal à supprimer ce qu'il
avait lui-même réclamé parce
qu'aujourd'hui si l'État
n'a pas ses crédits croisés il ne
pourrait pas intervenir sur bien des
domaines lorsqu'il demande
au département par exemple devenir
financer une route département une route
nationale c'est parce qu'il a besoin
aussi de ses crédits croisés voilà donc
il aurait eu du mal à supprimer ce qu'il
avait de lui-même
nécessaire il devait être suffisamment
important pour lui voilà donc merci en
tout cas oui
mais c'est ce que vous proposez parce
que je pense que c'est important que je
le dise on est aussi tant qu'à faire on
essaie de d'avoir soin de l'argent
public
quand on a une subvention européenne
normalement il y a zéro dette
aujourd'hui l'Europe sauf pour le plan
de relance n'emprunte pas quand on est
une subvention de d'État c'est 100% de
la dette je parle d'investissement
puisque comme l'état emprunte déjà pour
payer son fonctionnement quand la région
verse une subvention il peut y avoir un
peu de dette je vais prendre le cas de
l'Allier quand je donne 100 euros de
subvention à une commune j'ai 40% de
dette
il faut bien connaître que parfois les
communes ont très peu de recours à la
dette dans le meilleur des cas pour les
20% qu'il le reste à charge je rajoute
parce que c'est vos propos sur la
question des finances qu'on croisé et
des 10 millions d'euros de
Hautes-Pyrénées que faut pas non plus
mentir parfois les communes sont entre
guillemets toutes proportion sur les
ratiaux plus riches que ceux qui leur
apportent de l'argent en valeur absolue
c'est très modeste mais sur les
principes elles ont parfois un peu plus
de trésorerie et moins recours à
l'emprunt pour leurs investissements que
ceux qui les subventionnent
d'où l'instauration de mécanismes aussi
pour pour contrôler aussi les niveaux de
richesse des collectivités
auxquels on finance n'importe des
subventions en tout cas merci beaucoup à
tous les deux et à vos collaborateurs de
la DF merci pour cette audition plus
intéressante
et oui sans problème merci beaucoup au
revoir
[Applaudissements]